[musique]
moi
non
[musique]
moi
Ouais
Quatre jours
[musique]
Ce son que tout peut être fait comme 10 des 7 caniches de l'âme même maintenant
Je pense que c'est parce qu'il avait l'imagination nécessaire pour anthropomorphiser n'importe quelle technique.
moi
Après tout, le regarder guérit mon cœur et me donne une douce sensation
je me sens comme
J'ai
recherché
moi
Oh oh oh
non
Rien que de le regarder me fait sourire
Pour les déguisements
Ce gars juste à côté de moi dit que je peux lui serrer la main et l'embrasser
Au Japon, vous ne pouvez pas faire ça, n'est-ce pas?
[musique]
La couette s'adapte vraiment
être amical
8Yeux devenus agressifs envers l'autre partie
différent à nouveau
vous pouvez vous découvrir
non
moi